Transcription: Morgane Quilfen
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Il y a quelques semaines,
il m'est arrivé un truc
qui m'a pas mal fait réfléchir.
C'était l'anniversaire
d'une copine dans un bar
et je me suis retrouvée à côté d'un mec
que je ne connaissais pas.
On commence à discuter
et, assez rapidement,
il me demande ce que je fais
dans la vie, et je lui réponds :
« Je suis cheffe d'entreprise
et j'ai une marque de vêtements. »
Et le mec me demande :
« Ah ? Quoi comme vêtements ? »
et je lui réponds :
« En fait, on fait des vêtements
qui durent longtemps
pour ne pas avoir besoin
d'en racheter tous les quatre matins. »
Là, le mec s'arrête, me regarde
dans les yeux, et me dit :
« Ça ne marchera jamais.
Si les gens n'ont pas besoin
de racheter tes vêtements,
à un moment, ton entreprise
ne pourra plus grossir.
Et désolé, mais dans
ces conditions, je ne vois pas
comment une boîte comme la tienne
peut connaître la réussite. »
Pourquoi pense-t-il ça ?
Si je suis son raisonnement,
la réussite de mon entreprise,
ce serait de vendre
toujours plus de vêtements,
quitte à vendre de la mauvaise qualité ?
En gros pour lui, grossir, c'est réussir,
quel qu'en soit le prix.
Si par « réussir », on entend
« croissance infinie
du chiffre d'affaire »,
« amélioration perpétuelle
des profits », alors il a raison.
Effectivement, mon entreprise
n'est pas vraiment sur la route du succès,
contrairement à d'autres
dans le domaine du textile
qui, chaque année,
vendent plus de vêtements.
C'est le cas de Nike, H&M, Zara, Primark.
Seulement, leur croissance,
elle a une conséquence :
chaque année, on produit
plus de vêtements.
Entre 2000 et 2014,
la production mondiale de vêtements
a été multipliée par deux.
Pourquoi pas, si ça permet aux gens
de ne pas tous s'habiller
en jean, pull gris et chaussures blanches.
Le problème, c'est que pour produire
toujours plus de vêtements,
on rejette dans l'atmosphère
des millions de tonnes
de gaz à effet de serre, de CO2.
Est-ce que vous avez une idée
de ce que représente l'industrie textile
sur le volume total
de gaz à effet de serre ?
Papa ?
(Rires)
8,1 %.
C'est autant que l'ensemble
du transport routier de la planète.
Dans ces conditions,
est-ce qu'on peut continuer
à vouloir produire toujours plus
tout en luttant contre
le dérèglement climatique ?
A priori, ce n'est pas incompatible.
Il y a des entreprises
qui plantent des arbres
pour compenser le carbone
qu'elles émettent dans l'atmosphère.
Il y a des mecs qui bossent
sur des puits de carbone artificiels,
d'énormes machines qui aspirent
le CO2 de l'atmosphère.
J'ai même entendu parler d'un mec
qui aurait trouvé la solution
à la pollution plastique des océans.
Donc des solutions technologiques
qui permettent de concilier
croissance des entreprises
et protection de l'environnement,
on dirait qu'il y en a plein, non ?
Mais du coup, pourquoi est-ce que
le climat continue de se réchauffer ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'à chaque minute,
un peu plus de plastique
est déversé dans les océans ?
Pourquoi la biodiversité continue
à s'effondrer à un rythme inquiétant ?
Est-ce que ces solutions
sont suffisantes ?
Pour répondre à cette question,
j'ai lu pas mal de livres sur le sujet
et des rapports d'experts,
et le document qui, à mon sens,
résume le mieux la situation actuelle,
c'est une lettre
que des chercheurs ont écrite
suite aux marches
pour le climat de mars 2019.
Et je vais vous en lire un extrait.
« En l'état actuel de nos connaissances,
il n'existe pas
de solutions technologiques
qui permettent à toute la planète
d'avoir notre niveau de confort actuel
sans mettre en péril
le climat et le vivant.
Et les gens qui vous disent le contraire
se trompent par ignorance,
ont fait des erreurs de calcul,
ou mentent par intérêt. »
OK, ces solutions technologiques
n'existent pas encore,
mais il y a tellement de monde
qui bosse sur le sujet
qu'il y a quand même une chance
qu'on les trouve, non ?
Elle est de quoi, cette chance ?
Un pourcent ?
Soyons optimistes, 10 %,
10 % de chances qu'on trouve
une solution technologique
au dérèglement climatique.
Est-ce qu'on prend le risque ?
Imaginez, vous arrivez avec votre famille
devant un avion bringuebalant
et là, le pilote vous dit
qu'il y a 10 % de chances
qu'il arrive entier à destination.
Est-ce que vous montez dedans ?
Même s'il y avait 50 % ou 80 % de chances
que le trajet se passe bien,
ni vous, ni moi, ni personne ne montons
avec notre famille dans cet avion,
sauf Xavier Dupont de Ligonnès,
mais on en parlera une autre fois.
(Rires)
On ne peut pas compter
sur la technologie pour nous sauver
face à l'urgence climatique actuelle.
La seule chose qu'on puisse faire,
c'est de produire et consommer moins.
Quoi qu'on vous raconte,
quelles que soient les merveilles
high-tech agitées devant vous,
il y a une équation inchangeable :
produire, c'est polluer.
Il vaudra toujours mieux
produire un t-shirt que deux,
même si les deux sont en coton bio,
même si on plante des arbres derrière.
Du coup, il faut vraiment
changer notre état d'esprit.
On ne peut plus considérer
que la croissance des
entreprises est une réussite.
C'est cet état d'esprit
qui nous a mis dans la situation
de crise climatique actuelle.
La dernière fois que j'ai dit ça,
un mec s'est levé et m'a interpellée.
Il a fait un truc du genre :
« Vous êtes bien mignonne
avec votre discours
"décroissance-sauvons
la planète-écologie",
mais vous être bien contente
d'en vendre des pulls !
Moi, j'ai l'impression que votre discours,
c'est une manière de vous
différencier des autres marques
pour au final vendre plus. »
Avouez que c'est exactement
ce que vous êtes en train de vous dire.
Franchement, je comprends,
je ne vous en veux pas !
On l'a vu mille fois, toutes ces marques
qui prétendent soutenir
les luttes contre le racisme,
l'homophobie, le sexisme, la grossophobie,
juste pour faire parler d'elles
et derrière vendre plus.
Et en ce moment, c'est
ce qui se passe avec l'écologie.
Dans la plupart des entreprises,
l'environnement est vu comme
une manière d'augmenter les ventes.
Et le paradoxe, c'est que
plus les ventes augmentent,
plus la crise climatique s'aggrave.
Du coup, je comprends
que vous ayez envie
de prendre avec des pincettes
un discours de protection
de l'environnement
qui sort de la bouche
d'une cheffe d'entreprise.
En fait, on arrive même
à se demander si ça existe,
une entreprise qui ne cherche pas
la croissance à tout prix.
Pourquoi est-ce que mon entreprise
serait différente ?
Pour une raison simple :
dans mon entreprise, on a compris
que la taille optimale
n'est pas la taille maximale.
Grossir plus ne nous
rendra ni plus efficaces,
ni plus performants, ni plus heureux.
Nous sommes cinq à travailler
pour ma marque de vêtements,
et ça suffit pour fabriquer
et distribuer des vêtements de qualité
tout en étant rentables
et heureux d'aller au boulot chaque matin.
À quoi bon être cent fois plus nombreux ?
À quoi bon être cent fois plus gros ?
La réussite des entreprises
n'est pas leur croissance.
C'est à cause de leur obsession
pour la croissance
qu'on est dans l'état
d'urgence climatique actuel.
Pourtant, je crois qu'on a encore
besoin des entreprises.
On a besoin d'elles pour nous chauffer,
nous nourrir, nous habiller,
mais aussi pour rendre
nos téléphones plus réparables,
pas pour ajouter une troisième caméra ;
pour rendre nos voitures plus légères
pour consommer moins d'énergie,
pas pour les rendre plus puissantes ;
pour relocaliser
notre fabrication de vêtements,
pas pour faire des vestes connectées -
à quoi ça sert une veste connectée ?
Je crois qu'on a besoin d'un écosystème
de petites et moyennes entreprises utiles,
et pas d'un monde dominé
par quatre grosses boîtes
qui n'ont qu'une idée en tête :
doubler la concurrence.
Parce qu'une belle forêt qui résiste
n'est pas trois gros arbres
avec des troncs de 4 km de diamètre
qui auraient absorbé tous les autres.
Une forêt résiliente,
une forêt riche écologiquement,
ce sont des milliers d'arbres
de tailles et d'espèces différentes.
Et en fait, si vous regardez
un peu autour de vous,
des entreprises utiles ne cherchant pas
la croissance à tout prix, il y en a plein.
Il y a mon fournisseur
d'énergie, Enercoop,
le boulanger en bas de chez moi,
Bioseptyl, l'entreprise
qui fabrique ma brosse à dents,
la maraîchère
chez qui j'achète mes légumes
et même un mec qui a un restaurant
de poisson sur le bord de la Loire.
Il y en a des millions,
des petites et moyennes entreprises,
qui vont très bien
sans chercher à conquérir le monde.
Pourtant, ce n'est pas du tout
à ce genre d'entreprises-là
que le mec du bar,
dont je vous parlais au début,
pense quand il me parle
d'une boîte qui réussit.
Comment ça se fait ?
Il y en a autant autour de lui,
des petites entreprises qui vont bien.
Pourquoi quand il pense
à une entreprise qui réussit,
il pense à une grosse boîte
qui croît en permanence ?
Venez, on se met
deux minutes dans sa tête.
Vous êtes ce mec,
ou vous êtes quelqu'un
qui a très envie de monter une boîte,
ou vous êtes déjà
à la tête d'une entreprise,
et vous ouvrez le journal.
Vous verrez qu'on y célèbre
les levées de fonds records,
les entrées en bourse fracassantes.
Vous lirez que le Graal pour une
entreprise, c'est de devenir une licorne,
c'est-à-dire de valoir
un milliard d'euros.
Vous verrez qu'on récompense
les dirigeants des grandes entreprises
en les payant en moyenne
83 fois le salaire d'une aide-soignante.
Regardez à présent du côté
des récompenses officielles.
Vous verrez qu'on décerne
la Légion d'honneur
aux patrons des entreprises françaises
qui ont inondé le monde de leurs produits,
peu importe ce que ça a coûté
à notre société.
Ça a été le cas récemment
avec le patron de Sanofi,
l'entreprise pharmaceutique
responsable du scandale de la Dépakine,
un médicament qui a causé
des troubles mentaux et physiques
chez des dizaines de milliers d'enfants.
Rendez-vous à présent dans une librairie
et demandez à consulter
les biographies d'entrepreneurs
qui se vendent le mieux.
Vous verrez des ouvrages à la gloire
de ceux qui ont monté des empires
comme Nike ou Apple.
Vous lirez que ces personnes
sont présentées comme des modèles,
mais qu'on ne s'attarde pas
sur ce qu'on a sacrifié pour leur succès.
Vous saviez que dans les années 90,
on a découvert que c'étaient des enfants
qui fabriquaient les baskets Nike ?
Saviez-vous que les conditions de travail
dans les usines de nos iPhones
sont si déplorables qu'on les appelle
« les usines à suicide » ?
Dans l'imaginaire collectif,
la grosse boîte est glorifiée,
et ceux qui les ont montées
et les dirigent sont starifiés
et érigés comme modèles
au reste de la société.
Leur parcours, leur méthode, leur modèle
sont étudiés en école de commerce.
Or l'histoire nous a montré
que les volontés de conquête
mondiale sont mortifères.
C'est cette ambition,
celle de grossir toujours plus,
d'être plus gros que le voisin,
qui nous a poussés à piller,
à coloniser, à exterminer,
et à réduire en esclavage.
Oui, les entreprises ont
une énorme part de responsabilité
dans l'accroissement des inégalités
et dans la catastrophe climatique
qu'on est en train de vivre.
Elles sont aussi les mieux placées
pour freiner ce désastre,
et si elles ne s'y mettent pas,
je me demande si on a une chance.
Si on veut que la réussite des entreprises
ne se fasse plus ni aux dépens
des humains et de la planète,
il faut changer
notre définition de la réussite.
Et ça commence par changer
ses représentations.
Imaginez que vous ouvriez le journal
et que vous tombiez sur une double page
qui parle de Pierre Schmidt,
le patron d'une entreprise textile
en Alsace, connu pour deux choses :
avoir résisté aux sirènes
de la délocalisation
et avoir mis en place un système
de traitement des eaux usées exemplaire.
Imaginez qu'à votre librairie,
vous découvriez
que le best-seller du moment,
c'est le livre de Thomas Huriez,
l'homme qui a réussi à relocaliser
une filière de fabrication
de jeans en France.
Imaginez qu'en école de commerce,
on étudie le business model
de la boulangerie en bas de chez moi
qui, depuis 30 ans,
fait les mêmes produits,
vend les mêmes quantités,
et s'en porte plutôt bien.
Imaginez ce que ça serait
si la représentation de la réussite
n'était plus celle de la croissance.
J'ai une bonne nouvelle.
Les choses que je viens de vous décrire
sont déjà en train d'arriver.
Et il était temps.
Il est temps que la réussite ne soit plus
celle de l'argent,
mais de l'impact positif,
temps que les entreprises
œuvrent au bien collectif
et non à l'enrichissement de quelques-uns.
Oui, elles seront moins grosses,
mais c'est leur taille ou notre survie,
donc à choisir...
Oui, la définition de la réussite
est en train de changer,
et j'espère que ça ne s'arrêtera pas là.
J'espère que l'année prochaine,
quand mon amie fêtera
à nouveau son anniversaire
et que je me retrouverai dans un bar,
à côté d'un mec que je ne connais pas,
qu'on discutera et qu'il me demandera
ce que je fais, et je lui répondrai :
« Je suis cheffe d'entreprise,
j'ai créé une marque de vêtements
qui durent longtemps pour ne pas
avoir besoin d'en racheter souvent »
j'espère que le mec s'arrêtera,
me regardera dans les yeux et me dira :
« Ça ne marchera jamais,
tout le monde fait déjà ça. »
(Rires)
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements) (Acclamations)